gfr je pense qu'il va exploser guillaume
et j'y crois beaucoup joli il a beaucoup
beaucoup à perdre qui n'a pas gardé à
leur semble qui fait la quotidienne à la
a fait sien pourquoi tu n'as pas garder
alors parce que je ne garde merci pour
nous pas du tout je vais vous dire
pourquoi parce que guillaume il avait du
mal à venir on entrées sorties sur une
chronique c'est pas évident à faire
et voilà mais sinon je trouve très très
beau jeu les produits sur ces stars ça
marche également très bien ils ont
arrêté l'émission s'est toujours pas
pourquoi je crois que c'est pour mettre
des clips de jean luc lahaye merci sinon
est-ce que vous avez des infos puis ça
fait 15 ans qui fait la quotidienne à la
radio je pense qu'il a eue nous avons
nous envie en dépression il est en envie
de voeux de perte peut être autre chose
à mon avis internes ont comme ça ça se
récupère d'une manière ou d'une autre et
puis effectivement non seulement il ya
la volonté de la ligne éditoriale qui
doit changer mais tu parlais d'audience
benjamin je pense que les audiences sont
pas aussi vers celle là surtout
attendant c'est surtout combien elle
aimait qu'on va passer un autre truc
sujet un couple si les noisettes là il a
été viré va être remplacé par quelqu'un
à savoir qu'elle vient de rebondir
qu'annick on bal des rumeurs sur moi non
d'accord quand vous feriez baragnon
bayonne hommage à mme est proposé mais
ça